chris rock
had the ability the option
to have the lapd
go arrest and remove
will smith from their theater that night
that's an absolute fact the lapd made it
clear we will do
whatever you want us to do oscar's
producer will packer sharing surprising
details about the aftermath of the slap
heard around the world oh richard
oh wow
wow
while speaking with good morning
america's tj holmes packer reveals
shortly after will smith stormed the
stage and slapped chris rock he thought
what many viewers thought was it staged
i thought it was a bit i thought it was
a bit like everybody else i knew we
hadn't practiced it not concerned i
wasn't concerned at all because he's
walking when i said watch this he's
gonna kill because i knew he had an
amazing lineup of jokes that we had we
had him in the prompter and ultimately
he did not get to one
joke
he didn't tell one of the planned jokes
once i saw
will yelling at the stage with such
vitriol
my heart dropped
i never felt so immediately devastated
so what happens when chris rock gets
slapped he tries to bring humor to the
situation
the winners are walking off stage chris
is with them and i immediately go up to
chris
and you say what or you do what i said
did he really hit you
and
he looked at me and he goes yeah
he goes i just took a punch from
muhammad ali as only chris can he was
immediately you know in
in joke mode but you could tell that he
was very much still in shock and that
shocking moment involved the police the
lapd shared in a statement to e.t sunday
night they were aware of the incident
but the individual involved has declined
to file a police report and packer
reveals it's true i made that clear like
rock you tell me whatever you want to do
brother and he was telling me
i'm fine
let's just get past this i'm getting out
of here i can't believe this happened
the lapd
came and needed to talk to chris i said
rock let them let them finish and they
said you know would you like us to take
any action and he said no but the big
question following the incident was why
is will smith still in the room it
happened to be right before
the best actor award
shayla told me
that
they were about to physically remove
will smith i immediately went to
the academy leadership that was on site
and i said
chris rock doesn't want that packer also
reveals will reached out directly to say
sorry will smith um reached out to me
the next morning and
said
and he apologized and he said you know
this
this should have been a gigantic moment
for you and he expressed
his embarrassment and
and that was the extent of it will has
also since apologized to chris directly
on instagram writing i was out of line
and i was wrong i am embarrassed and my
actions were not indicative of the man i
want to be keep my wife's name
out
however e.t has learned that there has
been no reconciliation between the two
men
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
and when it comes to hearing rock side
of the story he revealed during his
comedy show wednesday night now's not
the time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and i'm still kind of processing
what happened
[Applause]
you